Her low freak bitches.
So,
so the reason I,
the reason I think a guy like that gets
that good especially so quick is because
he doesn't have a favorite part.
He doesn't like,
he loves the whole thing,
you know,
you know those guys that they're
good strikers and they love striking.
So that's what they
want to do all the time.
Like,
no,
he works in everything because for his
offense to be as good and as defense to
be just as good.
A lot of guys just want to be offensive.
Guys just want to win in the gym.
Guys want to get on top and they want
to stay there and they want to control.
So when those guys get put on their back,
they don't really know what to do or
they have a much harder time escaping or
transitioning out of that position.
But not a guy like that though.
Those are the best guys in the world.
You look at,
you look at Dj,
you look at dom,
I mean even Connor,
right?
Um,
the Nate fight is a bad example because
that was the first time he was in a
fight in the UFC and,
and he didn't like it the
second time he did better.
But at the same thing with Chad,
the little bit of a fight he was in
with Mendez when he was on his back,
he did some work,
got back to his feet.
He didn't,
he wasn't so uncomfortable with a,
with a dominant wrestler like that on top
that he wasn't going to be able to get
back up.
Yeah.
Well,
Connor is,
is definitely evolving.
You know,
you could definitely tell that he's,
uh,
like especially his approach
to the second Nate Diaz fight.
He fought that fight very smart and he
survived some moments where it looks like
he was gassing out,
or at least he got that
opportunity to reset.
If he wasn't gassing out,
it's definitely diminished.
But he managed it.
He managed it much better than
the first time because I mean,
when he got in trouble the first time,
he did try to change the game,
but when it wasn't in his favor,
it was like,
I kind of want Outta here.
[inaudible] spirit.
I mean,
as a fighter,
I look at that and I'm like,
his spirit kind of broke there.
But he asked for that fight again and
then he did it again and he did run into
some trouble and he improved
and he fought through it.
The second time he didn't,
he wasn't like,
oh,
this is a real fight.
Now I gotta get Outta here.
No,
he was like,
I'm staying right here.
So I'm excited to see that Conor
fight Eddie because I mean,
yeah,
Nate is the same kind of guy.
He's not going to worry
about those kinds of things.
But like Eddie is a different beast.
Eddie's that Philly beast.
He's a savage.
So I want to see,
I want to see them get into a fight,
like not that it could easily happen
to and we could easily happen.
Eddie Abras,
the fucking savage,
he really is.
He watched that Rafael dos Anjos stoppage.
Holy Shit.
The combination,
he hit him worth,
I mean,
and the,
the,
the sheer amount of punches he through
the barrage that it took to put them
away.
I mean he had some fucking serious
endurance to press the pace like that.
That's the one thing that
Connor has been struggling with,
right?
Yeah.
Would that pace and insurance and Eddie
has the power to put that pace on him
when,
when Nate gets him tired or
it gets him hurt on his feet,
he's got that power is not as dynamic.
He's,
he's a very strong guy too.
Like he's a very strong guy for one
55 I'm looking forward to that too.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm curious actually to see what
Connor looks like at 55 because right.
We haven't seen him there in the UFC.
We've seen 45 and then
you've seen him cut?
No wait and wait like one 69 I
think he weighed against Nate.
It would be interesting to see,
what does Connor look
like when he's at one 55?
I mean,
that might be the perfect weight for him.
It's entirely possible.
We might see a better McGregor at one 55.
I think that's the deepest division.
Yeah.
Um,
I think it has been for the
longest time and that if,
if,
if anybody dominates that division,
like Rda did it for a little,
he looked dominant for a little bit.
Um,
even coming up to the title fight,
he looked like he was going
to hold onto that for a while.
Um,
but everybody there so
close everybody that way.
Class is so close.
So if somebody does it,
but what about neuroma?
Grumet off because he ragdolled
everybody he's gotten in there with.
That's the one guy you can't say it's
close with because everybody he's got
ahold of,
he's beating the fuck out of that guy
is special no matter if it's special.
That's true.
I like,
I like that guy because what you said,
he's special.
Right?
And when you see that special thing,
then I guess people kind of get lost in
the void when everybody's close to being
just as good as each other.
Then you kind of just fight to get just
a little bit better than the other guy,
just a little bit better than the other.
I just gotta be better than him.
But then when you get the John Jones
that comes into the arena and he's,
she's leaps and bounds
ahead of everybody else,
then you realize there's a bigger
gap and guys start closing that.
Right?
Like a Alyse Alinka,
Alexandra Gusterson.
I mean,
he always fights at that level,
especially when he's in a title fight.
But I don't know if,
if John Jones didn't exist,
if he would rise to that occasion,
what I mean eat.
So,
so somebody's got to show up
in the lightweight division
at some point like that
too,
to make people raise their level.
Because guys right now,
which is the deepest
and toughest division,
but guys are so close and maybe
no Maga Madoff is that guy.
Hmm.
Well,
he certainly has been in
when it comes to grappling,
like what he did to dos Anjos was,
was pretty stunning,
you know,
because there was like,
man though Santos is a legit
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu black belt,
super strong guy,
really good on the ground and it
just seemed like [inaudible] off.
Just got ahold of them and just did
whatever the fuck you wanted to.
Once you've got them on the ground,
just throws dudes around.
It's almost like he's built different,
but he doesn't,
you know,
like if Gleason bow was
doing that to dude's,
I'd go,
I that makes sense.
Look at that fucking guy.
But when Norma Madoff does it,
it's not necessarily just some
overwhelming physical attribute.
It's his technique and his aggression.
Just just super fucking aggressive
and tight with his grappling in his
positioning,
his ground and pound as horrific.
He's a scary dude,
man.
He doesn't,
he doesn't even have to think
about the way he does those moves.
I remember when you said that and
when you say ragdoll on people in Rda,
Rda took that shot on him and he was
in the third and he hit him with it.
Uchi Mata basically right from the over
Hook whizzer and tripped him forcing it
and that's not easy.
Throw it a hit and
especially from that range,
it didn't look like it
was going to happen,
but he does it to the guy who goes on and
become the world champion that way and
then dominate other guys
at that weight class.
Yeah,
like that guy is special man.
I want to see,
I want to see him improve his standup
and get and get and just get better.
I want to see him do things like Dj is,
you know,
just working on his weaknesses and cause,
I mean that guy would never lose.
Imagine if he had Djs,
MMA Iq and skillset,
but his rest with his red.
What is wrestling and ground is
now like who's beating that guy?
I would send that guy
to fight wars for me.
Yeah,
man,
look,
he's,
he rocked dolls dudes in a
very unusual way and deal.
Every now and then a guy will come
up like that that can do that.
And he does it with
intensity and aggression.
Like Damien Maia,
rag dolls,
a lot of people too,
especially lately,
he gets ahold of guys like
I did with Rick story,
but he's doing it in like
this technical squeezy way.
You know when Norma grow
off gets a hold of dudes.
It's smash.
Everything is smash.
He's driving you into the ground,
smashing you into the ground that's
smashing when you're on top of you.
Damien Maia is just constricting.
He's like moving into position and he
slowly closing you off and he's gonna
choke you.
It's a totally different
kind of domination.
But then,
I don't know if it's entirely the fairest
comparison cause Damien is obviously
far a much longer career and he
fought at one 85 and he fought again.
Yeah,
it's against Anderson.
He got knocked out by Nate.
He's had a lot of ups and downs in
the UFC and Jake shields beat him.
People forget that.
Jake shields essentially
out grappled them.
But number coming off.
Good luck.
Good luck out.
Grapple on that dude.
Good luck.
But what's his,
what does it take down?
Percentage like two.
It's probably a million percent.
I mean,
he takes down everybody.
But the other thing about
number Grumet off is um,
uh,
then he gets injured a lot
and you've got to wonder,
is it because of that insane
fucking aggressive style of his,
it's so,
it makes it so fun to watch him.
He's that like you're kind of
red lining your body too much
probably.
Yeah.
Right.
I mean,
you got arrest,
right?
You gotta heal up.
You can't always be on.
Yeah.
But I mean,
can a guide like a Damien Maia
who trains very technically,
I mean obviously he wrestles and he
does like a lot of chaotic movements as
well,
but probably not nearly
what the kind of intensity,
the number of men off does.
You gotta wonder like a,
that style is obviously super effective
and very fucking devastating and fun to
watch.
But I wonder if preparing for that style
and executing that style is almost like
ultimately too much on your joints,
too much on your body.
I guess the question would be then is
can he be no Magna Madoff without that
style?
Does he have the skill to translate
that to slowing it down and,
and,
and turning the volume down?
Yeah.